no es lo mismo ver el trabajo de bukele
desde fuera del país que desde dentro
cómo se explica esta contradicción entre
la alta aprobación y las denuncias en su
contra
Bueno realmente hay una explicación
lógica y es que este gobierno tiene una
maquinaria publicitaria o maquinaria de
propaganda
muy significativa muy grande se producen
más de 100 videos diarios hay muchos
actores en redes sociales
proyectando la imagen de bukele los
proyectos de bukele Y eso ha alcanzado a
límites insospechables verdad es un es
una estrategia bukele proviene del del
mundo de la publicidad tenía una agencia
de publicidad antes de ser presidente
conoce muy bien cómo funcionan las redes
sociales y
digamos se proyecta muchísimo es algo
que hemos monitoreado durante estos
cuatro años
centrándonos en las denuncias de
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos quien
se encarga de investigar hay entidades
lo suficientemente independientes en el
país para determinar estos delitos
Lamentablemente la única instancia de la
que tenemos datos es el informe reciente
de Cristo sal las demás instituciones
del estado la procuraduría de Derechos
Humanos la fiscalía general de la
república Prácticamente todo el aparato
del Estado está en manos de bukele todo
parte desde él y apunta hacia el
Entonces no hay datos no casi todo está
reservado no no tenemos información y
con lo único que contamos son con
informes bastante limitados y esfuerzos
de algunos organismos fundaciones y ongs
que están preocupadas por el tema de los
derechos humanos o por lo que ha llamado
el gobierno efectos colaterales
si bien es cierto ha disminuido hay que
reconocer el número de homicidios ha
bajado
el plan ha sido efectivo en cuanto
capturas pero también
aparecen estos daños colaterales por el
estado de excepción en donde se han
capturado muchos jóvenes de comunidades
desprotegidas desfavorecidas que no
tienen acceso
a a una pronta y cumplida justicia no
tienen acceso a abogados y Y hay muchos
cuestionamientos sí sobre
las garantías mínimas bueno busqué el
expresado abiertamente que quiere ser
reelegido ya en 2021 la corte
constitucional abrió esta puerta con el
panorama actual es factible que tenga
otro mandato
pues Aparentemente
todo indica que sí Pese a que la
Constitución salvadoreña tiene cinco
artículos que limitan la reelección el
mismo bukele lo había dicho muchos años
antes de que no podía haber reelección
de hecho en la toma de Posesión él dice
que estos son cinco años claves para
transformar el país pero ahora con el
control de la corte y de las demás
instancias políticas se ha abierto un
espacio para la reelección muy polémico
muy cuestionado y todo indica que que se
va a lanzar en las próximas elecciones